[Música]
en Colombia el presidente Gustavo Petro
visitó a los niños que fueron hallados
el viernes tras permanecer 40 días en
una selva del sur occidente del país los
menores reciben atención médica en un
hospital de Bogotá donde el equipo
interdisciplinario aseguró que sus
condiciones son aceptables
en su primer acto público tras ser
imputado por 37 cargos el expresidente y
precandidato republicano Donald Trump se
burló del proceso en su contra aseguró
que es parte de la cacería de brujas que
adelanta el partido demócrata
en Ecuador el correísmo postuló a la ex
asambleísta Luisa González como
candidata a las elecciones anticipadas
del 20 de agosto esto luego de que el ex
vicepresidente Jorge glass condenado por
corrupción rechazar a la nominación
ampliamos desde quito
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Colombia donde los niños que se
perdieron durante 40 días en la selva
del guaviare se recuperan ahora en el
hospital Militar de Bogotá la capital
del país a pesar de tener solo cinco
nueve Trece y apenas un año los menores
consiguieron sobrevivir en la selva y
muchos se preguntan Cómo Alba Santana
tiene los detalles
es una historia que ha sorprendido al
mundo entero la supervivencia de cuatro
niños en la selva del guaviare Colombia
tras 40 días ha perdido el primero de
mayo el avión en el que viajaban se
estrelló en la mitad de la selva pero
los menores de 5 9 13 y un año
sobrevivieron
el dispositivo de búsqueda dio con
pruebas de ello como un biberón fruta
mordisqueada o huellas pero a pesar de
estar muy cerca no consiguieron
encontrarlos hasta el 9 de junio y lo
más sorprendente con vida estaban en la
Vereda Palma Rosa a tan solo 5 km de
donde se estrelló su avión y a pesar de
tener signos de desnutrición con buen
estado de salud en general algo que hace
saltar una pregunta cómo lograron
sobrevivir 40 días en mitad de la selva
la respuesta se encuentra en la
cosmovisión indígena del mundo y la
conexión que tienen con la naturaleza
los grupos indígenas colombianos
aseguran que la misma selva los protegió
o que posiblemente se encontraron con
grupos no contactados a presentes en la
región además los niños del pueblo
indígena huitoto en especial los dos
mayores sabían manejarse por la selva
la sobrevivencia de los niños es una
muestra del conocimiento y
relacionamiento con el medio natural de
la vida el cual se enseña desde el
vientre de la madre los indígenas no
entienden el mundo igual y según su
cosmovisión en la selva nunca se pierde
nadie es un tránsito del que se puede
volver o no un episodio que según dijo
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
quedará en la historia del país
Donald Trump aprovechó su primer mitin
de campaña para reaccionar luego de ser
imputado de 37 cargos por esconder miles
de documentos algunos de ellos altamente
confidenciales cuando abandonó la Casa
Blanca pero el multimillonario que
espera ganar Las primarias republicanas
culpa a la justicia de acusarlo
injustamente para apartarlo del poder
Gabriel corcho nos cuenta más
primera aparición pública de Donald
Trump desde su imputación el viernes el
expresidente y precandidato a las
presidenciales de 2024 estuvo en el
estado de Georgia en una convención de
su partido donde movilizó a los
republicanos para obtener la nominación
Trump acusa a la justicia de intentar
apartarlo del poder con acusaciones
injustas
la ridícula infundada acusación contra
mí por parte del departamento de
injusticia de la Administración biden
pasará la historia como uno de los más
horribles abusos de poder en la historia
de nuestro país
está intentando encarcelar a su
principal oponente político el viernes
la justicia Federal reveló los 37 cargos
de acusación contra Trump que incluyen
retención ilegal de documentos
clasificados y obstrucción a la justicia
la fiscalía alega que el expresidente
guardó miles de documentos algunos ellos
altamente confidenciales cuando se fue
de la Casa Blanca en 2021 unos de estos
documentos incluirían información sobre
el programa nuclear de Estados Unidos
mientras Donald Trump niega las
acusaciones que calificó de broma la
fiscalía insistió sobre la gravedad de
los supuestos delitos a pesar de ser el
primer expresidente de Estados Unidos en
ser imputado por cargos federales Donald
Trump sigue siendo el favorito para las
primarias republicanas de 2024 en las
cuales se nominará el candidato del
partido para las presidenciales que se
enfrentará previsiblemente
en Washington asientos de personas
asistieron al evento en la casa blanca
para celebrar el mes del orgullo lgtbiq
más el presidente Joe biden le dio la
bienvenida a los asistentes y pronunció
un sentido mensaje en el que resaltó la
importancia de la inclusión en un
momento en que se ha registrado un
aumento en las legislaciones o proyectos
de ley discrimina torios en varios
estados se trató del mayor evento del
orgullo organizado en la Casa Blanca
en Ecuador el partido Revolución
ciudadana liderado por el expresidente
Rafael Correa eligió a Luisa González
como candidata a las elecciones
anticipadas del 20 de agosto esto luego
de que el ex vicepresidente Jorge glass
rechazarla la nominación para evitar
problemas con su inscripción pues tiene
dos condenas en firme por corrupción y
una acusación de la fiscalía por un
tercer caso Gustavo Ortega corresponsal
de France 24 en Quito nos dio más
detalles al respecto
Jorge glass fue designado como el
candidato a la presidencia de la
República por el correísmo para las
elecciones generales anticipadas del 20
de agosto pero la designación duró poco
y el propio ex vicepresidente declinó
hacer el representante del correísmo
para buscar a la Silla presidencial de
LED en medio de un acto masivo de la
Revolución ciudadana designó a subir una
presidencial y el propio glass declaró
Yo sigo bajo ataque y vienen más
procesos penales días antes Jorge glass
había recibido una medida cautelar a su
favor que le devolvía sus derechos
políticos y con ello su Retorno a la
palestra medida que generó todo tipo de
reacciones realizando la normativa
electoral es que glass fue condenado a
seis años es como autor del delito de
asociación ilícita el caso odebrecht y
ocho años por cohecho en el caso soborno
sin embargo las dos condenas se
unificaron y logró obtener su libertad
condicional Julio será ahora la ex
asambleísta Luisa González quien buscará
la presidencia y Andrés arauz repetirá
pero ahora por la vicepresidencia de la
república
el Correa afirmó durante una reciente
entrevista que el plan del Movimiento
Político será convocar una asamblea
Constituyente Buscar la elección
indefinida destinar nuevas autoridades
del Estado eliminar los procesos
judiciales en contra de los líderes del
correísmo e inclusive Rafael Correa
buscaría ser candidato una vez anulada
la consulta popular de 2018 y enfrentar
la justicia la fiscal general del estado
Diana Salazar afirmó La papeleta
electoral ya toma fuerza con ocho
candidaturas presidenciales Juan topic o
tosón Pérez Daniel Novoa Fernando
villavicencio Javier
González que serán confirmados cuando
finalice el paso para inscribir las
candidaturas y del 8 al 17 de agosto
Ecuador vivirá una de sus campañas
electorales más intensas en Honduras Hay
polémica y críticas por el viaje de la
presidenta Xiomara Castro China la
mandataria rompió recientemente
relaciones con Taiwán y restableció
relaciones con Beijing el pasado 8 de
junio el gobierno chino abrió su
embajada en Tegucigalpa y la mandataria
estará en el país asiático hasta el 14
de junio Kenia Torres corresponsal de
France 24 en Honduras nos amplió la
información
las relaciones diplomáticas entre
Honduras y chinas se siguen consolidando
Hace unos días fue aperturada en
Tegucigalpa la embajada de ese país
asiático mientras que en este momento
una comitiva del gobierno encabezada por
la presidenta Xiomara Castro se
encuentra Precisamente en China sin
embargo en Honduras Existen algunas
preocupaciones a raíz de la ruptura con
Taiwán Uno de ellos es el sector
camaronero Quienes públicamente se han
expresado
preocupados porque Taiwán era justamente
uno de los destinos de exportación de
este importante rubro por otro lado
también existe preocupación por el
destino de más de 150 estudiantes
hondureños que estaban becados en
diferentes universidades en Taiwán sin
embargo en ese sentido china ha
expresado públicamente su interés de
recibir a algunos de ellos Mientras
tanto otros de estos hondureños serán
becados por el gobierno de Castro
finalizamos en México donde cientos de
ciclistas salieron desnudos a protestar
en la capital para promover el uso de la
bicicleta sobre el auto los ciudadanos
hicieron un recorrido de 15 kilómetros
en el que también exigieron respeto por
los ciclistas la idea de la movilización
era darles una mayor visibilidad y que
los conductores de autos y otros
vehículos sean conscientes de las normas
para garantizar la seguridad de los
usuarios de bicicletas se estima que
unas cinco cinco punto seis millones de
bicicletas son usadas en Ciudad de
México a diario
fin de la informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]